[Music]
so
my name is jay campanell i'm a ninth
grader at the liberal arts and sciences
academy and this is my story of how i
started using our
through school project so i'm from
austin texas and in austin there are a
lot of things that make us so austin
and one of those things is our very
passionate love towards tacos and
specifically breakfast tacos
we will constantly debate other people
on who we think make the best breakfast
tacos
so what if we could take a scientific
approach to see who really makes the
best breakfast tacos in austin
so the my solution to this question was
the taco index
which was a way of objectively reviewing
the different tacos in austin by
measuring them
on their total weight their weight
without their tortillas and the
thickness of their tortillas
so like the procrastinator i am i didn't
start working on this until i absolutely
had to
and that was my capstone project the
only criteria was that it had my project
had to help the community in some way
and i thought the taco index did that
perfectly so
i started working on this as a book
because it was inspired off the shanghai
soup dumpling index
that was a book but the more i worked on
that the more i knew that that's not
what i wanted to do
so i went to my mom and i asked her what
do you think i should do
and she told me to use r so like the
good son i am
i took her advice and used r but
i had very little idea on what r was and
definitely not how to
use it the only exposure i got to it was
tagging along to the cities where our
studio
conference was with my parents and the
trip to harry potter worlds with
unlimited butter beer
and extremely overpriced wands
so i was confused i didn't know what to
do
so i like every art programmer i went to
google
and i search what i need to do so i
searched how do i put a google sheet in
r
and i clicked on one of the first links
copy pasted the code
and then tweaked it until it worked for
me
and eventually i got a blank google
sheen to r
and i thought that was pretty impressive
for myself
so i had this blank google sheet in and
now i just needed some data
so that's when we started going out and
measuring the different tacos in austin
specifically the migas taco
because it was the breakfast taco of
austin
and we used tools like a scale and
calipers to measure these tacos which
got many
awkward and weird stairs from other
people but we cut through the
awkwardness and eventually
we had our google sheet full of data so
this was the school project and at my
school the only tools available to us
are chromebooks and of course our and
our studio
don't run on chromebooks so i to work on
this project
through rstudio cloud and with the help
of my mom
in google we built the app up to where
it is
today so this is it this is the
final product tacoindex.com and we
use the we use a graph to compare the
different tacos based on the five
different key points and you can click
and compare the
different tacos there you can also click
and see a map list and profiles and
about page of all the different places
and tacos that we tried
so after completing this project i no
longer feel
intimidated to just open r up and start
working and i've started to really enjoy
it
but this project wouldn't have been
anywhere as good as it was without the
help and encouragement i got from my mom
so i hope all the parents here at least
show their kids are because maybe
they'll love it as much as i do
and i'm excited to continue our in the
future thank you very much